in this lesson we're going to talk about
circles and the angles that you
sometimes have to solve for when working
with circles so this is just a brief
review of what you learned in geometry
but you can see in this first
diagram here we've got
angle aob this is actually called a
central angle because the vertex is at
the center of the circle
and
you have this arc right here arc a b
which is 45 degrees if we want to find
the measure of angle aob that central
angle it's going to be the same as the
intercepted arc it's also going to be 45
degrees as opposed to when you look at
this diagram over here where you can see
the vertex okay of angle wlx is right on
the circle that's called an inscribed
angle and the measure of angle wlx is
actually going to be half
of the intercepted arc so instead of 40
this is going to be half of 40 20.
over here you can see when you have a
line of tangency okay a line that's
tangent to the circle at just one point
when you draw a radius to that point of
tangency you want to remember that this
is a right angle a 90 degree angle
and then over here we've got an angle
which is outside the circle and we
actually have two secants that are
cutting through the circle at two points
here angle one you would actually take
the difference
okay of the two arcs and divide by two
so that's 60 minus two which is 40
divided by two which is 20 degrees so
we're taking the larger arc minus the
smaller arc divided by two and then this
last example
here we have two chords that intercept
okay
intersect inside the circle not
necessarily at the center and to find
the measure of angle one here what we do
is we actually average
the two intercepted arcs so we would add
100 plus 80 and then divide by two so
it's like an average so in this case it
comes out to 90 degrees for this angle
right here so this is just a brief
review of some of the angles and the
properties that you learn in geometry
when you studied circles i'll see you in
the next lesson